Speaking of reelection, uh, there is something
very unusual happening in the democratic primary
Republican turn Democrat.
Michael Bloomberg is instantly polling 6%
in one recent poll and an average of 4% immediately
surpassing many candidates who have been in
this thing for six months, a year even longer.
Uh, the new poll in which Michael Bloomberg
has polling 6% is from the Hill.
Michael Bloomberg is of course the turbo billionaire
who is somewhere between 10 and 20 times richer
than our current billionaire president Donald
Trump.
He has actually shaken up the race.
If you look at the polling with Bloomberg
in the race, you see that in the polls in
which Bloomberg is included, there are currently
five being used to calculate Bloomberg's average
of 4%.
You see that Joe Biden's support is mostly
unchanged, but both Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders support is down.
Tulsi.
Gabbert has gone from polling one to three
in recent polls to polling just zero to two.
Camila Harris is polling as low as two once
you include Bloomberg, despite having been
as high as five or 6% in recent polls, there
are now discussions that Camilla Harris may
soon be exiting this race altogether.
So let me get all the normal disclaimers out
of the way.
I'm not supporting Michael Bloomberg.
I already got heat yesterday merely by pointing
out that Pete Buddha judge has been climbing
in the polls.
People saying, David, you're a booted judge,
establishment shill.
I'm not supporting Pete.
I'm not supporting Michael Bloomberg.
I'm simply telling you the numbers.
Michael Bloomberg is very quickly having impact
that many candidates who have been in this
thing for six to 12 months have not been able
to make Deval.
Patrick, when he got into the race, wanted
to make at least this level of impact has
failed to do so.
And Michael Bloomberg is doing it to a degree
now.
Can he make the debates?
On the one hand, Bloomberg has until December
12th to qualify on polling and donor numbers.
Right now it is only Biden, Sanders, Warren,
Buddha, judge Harris and Clover char.
There are six people in the next debate.
If qualification closed today, Tom Stier would
be out.
Tulsi Gabard would be out, Andrew Yang would
be out, Cory Booker and Julio on Castro would
not make the next debate.
And of course, as of today, neither would
Bloomberg or Deval.
Patrick Bloomberg may easily end up qualifying
on polling.
The question is going to be donors, and I
actually don't know the answer to this.
Bloomberg is not even accepting donations.
He's financing his own campaign.
Can he even make the debate on that basis?
Since there is a donor requirement, he may
preclude himself from even maybe qualifying
because of that.
Uh, he's been spending millions of dollars
on ads.
Tons of our viewers have been telling me they're
regularly getting Michael Bloomberg ads before
our videos on YouTube.
The debate itself scheduled for December 19th.
So what does this mean for Bloomberg?
We have no polling from Iowa and New Hampshire,
Nevada or South Carolina, yet that includes
Michael Bloomberg, 6% nationally or 4% nationally
is not going to mean much if he can't make
any headway in any of those first four primaries.
I see Iowa as a very tough one for Michael
Bloomberg.
New Hampshire is maybe more of a possibility.
Nevada and South Carolina are certainly question
marks, but imagine being in this race for
months and months and then you see Bloomberg
enter and now you're instantly losing to him.
Like if I were working for Camila Harris or
Andrew Yang, Amy Klobuchar, a Corey Booker
Tulsi Gabard Julio on Castro, you just can't
seem to get past one to 3% in Harris's case.
She actually was up to 11 or 12% at one point,
but has just fallen apart and then you see
Michael Bloomberg come in and he's averaging
4% and getting 6% in one poll.
I would be extremely demoralized if I were
the candidates, if I were working on their
campaigns.
I don't work on political campaigns, but that,
that's my sense of it.
No doubt.
This is going to hugely encourage Michael
Bloomberg.
If he makes that next debate.
I wouldn't be surprised to see him get quite
a bit of FaceTime merely for being able to
get this level of support in just a few weeks
after announcing.
This does not, by the way, seemed like a particularly
fun time to be an Elizabeth Warren supporter.
She has been in freefall, as I told you yesterday
for several weeks now with Michael Bloomberg
in and climbing.
I can't imagine.
This is what Elizabeth Warren and her supporters
want to see.
Where will we be two weeks from now?
No idea.
Absolutely no idea.
This is a primary that is very quickly taking
on some different dynamics to say the least.
And I wouldn't be surprised if, uh, everything
reverses in the next two weeks and we simply
see a Warren Bernie Biden recover and be very
clearly the only people in front runner status.
Or we may see Buddha judge continue to climb.
We may see Michael Bloomberg get more traction.
I have no idea.
And of course for Michael Bloomberg, the possibility
of making that next debate, if indeed it is
even a possibility, given that he is financing
his own campaign will be a big factor in how
this thing plays out.
Let me know what you think.
We'll have a poll on our Instagram page about
this at David Pakman show.
And while you're there, follow me.
Me on Instagram as well@davidgotpackagedthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com